what is nineteen thousands plus seven
tens first let's think about what are 19
thousands and what are seven tens and
then from there we can add them so
nineteen thousands would quite literally
be if we had a thousand nineteen times
so there's a thousand one time if we had
a thousand two times we would have two
thousand if we had a thousand three
times we would have 1,000 2,000 3,000
and the pattern here should be pretty
clear if we have nineteen thousands or a
thousand nineteen times we would have
nineteen thousand so nineteen thousand
is literally nineteen thousands and then
seven tens same thing we could have
seven tens we could have ten seven times
so ten plus another ten plus another ten
and this one's a little simpler to do
than the nineteen will have to last
seven tens this time that's six tens and
there are seven tens so seven tens would
be literally seven tens or ten twenty
thirty forty fifty sixty seventy so
seven tens is seventy and then if we
wanted to combine these or add these we
would have nineteen thousands zero
hundreds the seven tens and zero ones or
nineteen thousand seventy we could have
also thought about that question in
terms of place value instead of listing
out all the thousands and listing out
all the tens we could have thought of
the place values we had nineteen
thousands which means we want our last
digit than nine to be in the thousands
place value and then the other digit we
had one would go in front of it
so this is red nineteen thousands and by
writing that thousands there we covered
all these empty place values or the
three zeros
we ended up adding the thousands can be
represented by these three zeros at the
end whereas 7/10 we put a seven in the
tens place and again we have an empty
place value behind it we had no ones
with it the tens by saying tens we
implied this zero after it so the
thousands added these three zeros to the
end and seven tens added one zero to the
end and again if we combined them like
we saw in the previous one we'd have
nineteen thousand zero hundreds and
seven tens so either way whether we list
out what nineteen thousands is literally
with nineteen thousands or seven tens
literally ten seven times or we look at
in terms of place value and add the
zeros on the end either way our solution
will be nineteen thousand seventy here's
one more we have five ten thousands plus
twenty two thousands so two ways again
we could try to try to solve this one we
could think about what are five ten
thousands if we had ten thousand five
times another ten thousand another
that's three four ten thousands and five
ten thousands that would be a total of
50 thousand ten thousand twenty thirty
forty fifty thousand so five ten
thousands is 50 thousand let's write
that up here fifty thousand plus 22
thousands 20 mm remember when we did the
nineteen thousands if we wrote one 1000
it would be a thousand if we wrote a
thousand two times it would be mm if we
wrote it 20 two times then it would be
twenty-two thousands there will be 20 mm
and we could combine these numbers 50
thousand
Plus 22,000 will be a total of 72,000 so
one way there that first way we talked
about is to think about what does five
ten thousands look like and what do
twenty two thousand look like to get our
numbers and then add them or the other
way we could solve this is with a place
where you chart is thinking about place
value so let's put a place value chart
in here and then put our first number
which was five ten thousand so we have
five in the ten thousandths place
five ten thousands and we can fill in
the zeros behind it in these empty place
values there were no thousands hundreds
tens or ones so for ten thousands we
added four zeros behind it and the other
number was twenty two thousand so twenty
two we read this as twenty two thousand
always saying the place value of the
last non-zero digit we see so 22 and
then thousand and then with thousands
like before we'll add three zeros to the
end and finally when we combine these
numbers when we look at the place values
we now have seven ten thousands we have
two thousands still no hundreds no tens
and no ones so our solution for five ten
thousands plus twenty mm is seventy-two
thousand